.
>> Sean: AND THEY ARE STILL
UNDER FIRE AS WE SPEAK.
FROM THE PENTAGON TONIGHT,
THANK YOU JENNIFER GRIFFIN.
IF THERE WAS ANY DOUBT, CLEARLY
RUSSIA'S INVASION IS ABOUT TO
GET WAY, WAY WORSE THAN EVEN
MANY ANTICIPATED WITH MORE
INDISCRIMINATE BOMBING RAIDS
AGAINST INNOCENT CIVILIANS, AND
TODAY, FOX NEWS LEARNED THAT
RUSSIA HAS DRAFTED PLANS TO
CONDUCT PUBLIC EXECUTIONS AND
UKRAINIAN CITIES ONCE THEY'VE
BEEN CAPTURED.
RUSSIA BUSTERS MURDERING THUG
VLADIMIR PUTIN, HAS GOT TO BE
STOPPED BY SOMEBODY THAT I HAVE
SAID REPEATEDLY NO, NOT ONE
AMERICAN BOOT ON THE GROUND,
I'VE CALLED FOR BOTH AMERICA AND
EUROPE, IF YOU WANT THE
SANCTIONS WILL WORK, THE FIRST
SANCTION, THE TOP SANCTION, THE
MOST IMMEDIATE DAMAGE YOU COULD
DO TO PUTIN'S ECONOMY IS TO STOP
IMPORTING ENERGY FROM RUSSIA AND
FOR AMERICA TO IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO ENERGY INDEPENDENCE AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE LIKE WE
ACHIEVED UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP.
I SUPPORT AMERICA SUPPLYING
UKRAINE WITH THE JAVELIN
MISSILES LIKE PRESIDENT TRUMP
DID.
I HAD MY DOUBTS AT THE TIME.
AND AMERICA SUPPLYING STINGER
MISSILES TO UKRAINE LIKE
PRESIDENT REAGAN PROVIDED,
AFGHANISTAN IN THE '80s.
I ALSO ADD THAT ANYONE INVADES A
SOVEREIGN COUNTRY, EVEN ONE WITH
A HISTORY OF CORRUPTION LIKE
UKRAINE -- WE'VE BEEN VERY
OUTSPOKEN ABOUT IT --
QUID PRO QUO JOE, AND IF THEY
KILL INNOCENT MEN, WOMEN,
CHILDREN LIKE VLADIMIR PUTIN HAS
HERE, THEY FORFEIT THEIR RIGHT
TO LEAD A COUNTRY.
THEY DESERVE TO BE TAKEN OUT BY
ANY MEANS NECESSARY AND OUR HOPE
IS MAYBE SOMEONE IN
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S INNER CIRCLE
HAS A CONSCIENCE AND A SOUL AND
WOULD BE ABLE TO REFUSE TO BE A
PART OF A REGIME THAT IS GUILTY
OF MURDERING WOMEN AND CHILDREN.
MEANWHILE, EVERY DOLLAR THAT WE
SPEND ON RUSSIAN OIL IS A DOLLAR
THAT GOES RIGHT INTO
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S FUND FOR HIS
WAR CRIMES IN UKRAINE AND RIGHT
NOW WE ARE SPENDING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS BUYING OVER
600,000 BARRELS OF OIL FROM
RUSSIA EVERY SINGLE DAY.
AND AS DEMOCRAT JOE MANCHIN
SAID, WE EITHER EXPAND OUR
FOSSIL FUEL INDUSTRY HERE, OR WE
END UP COMPROMISED JUST LIKE
COUNTRIES LIKE GERMANY.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> WE HAVE TO HAVE ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE, YOU CANNOT BE THE
SUPERPOWER OF THE WORLD IF YOU
HAVE TO DEPEND ON OTHER NATIONS
TO PRODUCER ENERGY.
AND I'M JUST IN A DIFFERENT
PLACE THAN MY CAUCUS, OR THE
COLLEAGUES, OR THE PRESIDENT,
AND THEY HAVE A HARD TIME COMING
TO GRIPS THAT YOU'VE GOT TO USE
EVERYTHING YOU'VE GOT.
IF GOT TO USE YOUR GAS, YOU GOT
TO USE YOUR CALL, YOU'VE GOT TO
YOUR OIL AND YOU HAVE TO DEVELOP
WIND AND SOLAR AT HYDRO AND
GEOTHERMAL NET HYDROGEN.
ALL OF THESE THINGS ON FOUR, BUT
I'M NOT GOING TO LEAVE US AND
AVOID.
I JUST NOT GOING TO BASICALLY GO
DOWN THAT PATH AND END UP LIKE
GERMANY DID.
>> Sean: JOE MANCHIN IS 100%
RIGHT.
WE HAVE ENOUGH OIL, WE HAVE
ENOUGH GAS, WE HAVE ENOUGH
RESOURCES IN AMERICA TO SUPPLY
OUR OWN ENERGY NEEDS AND THE
NEEDS OF OUR ALLIES FOR 100
YEARS PLUS.
THE EUROPEAN UNION ALSO HAS
TREMENDOUS AMOUNTS OF NATIONAL
ENERGY.
THEY ARE NOT USING IT.
TAKE A LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
EUROPE'S DEPENDENCE ON RUSSIAN
GAS IS NOT A NECESSITY.
IT'S A CHOICE THEY'VE MADE.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, ANNA FAKE
POLITICAL EFFORT TO GO GREEN,
EUROPEAN GOVERNMENT LITERALLY
STOPPED TAPPING THEIR OWN SUPPLY
OF NATURAL GAS AND THEN IMPORTED
IT FROM RUSSIA.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, EUROPE GETS
40% OF THEIR NATURAL GAS FROM
RUSSIA.
PUTIN HAS THEM, LITERALLY, NO
PUN INTENDED, OVER A BARREL.
TODAY EVEN NANCY PELOSI CAME OUT
IN SUPPORT OF BANNING ALL
RUSSIAN OIL IMPORTS INTO THE
U.S., LIKELY AN ELECTION-YEAR
CONVERSION, BUT SHE STILL HAS
YET TO SPEAK OUT ABOUT AMERICA
ONCE AGAIN RECLAIMING ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE.
OF COURSE JOE BIDEN, HE JUST
ISN'T WILLING TO MAKE THAT
COMMITMENT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> MR. PRESIDENT.
MR. PRESIDENT, SPEAKER  --
MR. PRESIDENT, SPEAKER PELOSI
SAYS -- SPEAKER PELOSI SAYS
RUSSIAN OIL SHOULD BE BANNED.
WHY NOT DO IT NOW?
>> WILL SANCTIONS BE ENOUGH?
>> OUT THE DOOR.
>> WILL YOU BAN RUSSIAN OIL?
>> Sean: REMEMBER JONI'S
PERMISSION TO ANY QUESTIONS.
IT'S PATHETIC.
LATER IN THE AFTERNOON JEN PSAKI
CIRCLED BACK TO THOSE QUESTIONS
AND SAID THERE'S ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING ABIDE IN A
ADMINISTRATION CAN DO TO CURB
OUR DEPENDENCE ON FOREIGN OIL.
ALL OF THE RESTRICTIONS THAT
THEY HAVE PLACED ON ENERGY
EXPLORATION AND PRODUCTION IS
SOMETHING THEY CAN STOP AND LIFT
IMMEDIATELY.
AND TO BLAME THE OIL COMPANIES
IS LAUGHABLE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> JUST SAID THE CRISIS IS NOT
AN HOUR STRATEGIC INTEREST TO
REDUCE THE SUPPLY.
WE ALSO KNOW THE PRESIDENT AS
RECENTLY AS YESTERDAY TALKED
ABOUT INCREASING DOMESTIC
MANUFACTURING TO BRING DOWN
CRISIS INFLATED ITEMS LIKE GOOD.
SO WHY NOT APPLY THE SAME LOGIC
TO ENERGY AND INCREASED DOMESTIC
PRODUCTION HERE?
>> Secretary Psaki: THERE ARE
9,000 APPROVED OIL LEASES THAT
THE OIL COMPANIES ARE NOT
TAPPING INTO CURRENTLY, SO I
WOULD ASK THEM THE QUESTION.
>> YOU THINK THAT OPENING THE
KEYSTONE PIPELINE AND HAVING
MORE ENERGY-FROM THE POLICIES
MIGHT DO THAT?
>> THE KEYSTONE PIPELINE HAS
NEVER BEEN OPERATIONAL.
IT WOULD TAKE YEARS FOR THAT TO
HAVE ANY IMPACT.
>> Sean: THEY SHUT DOWN
AUCTIONS, THE SHUTDOWN
EXPLANATION, THEY SHUT ON
ALASKA, SHUTDOWN AND MORE, THE
KEYSTONE XL PIPELINE AND
JEN PSAKI IS BASICALLY JUST
LYING.
UNDER THE LESS THAN
ADMINISTRATION, THE U.S. WAS A
NET EXPORTER OF ENERGY.
JOE BIDEN GAVE THAT UP BECAUSE
HE CAVED TO THE RADICAL NEW
GREENDALE SOCIALISTS THAT RUN
HIS PARTY.
THAT WAS BEFORE JOE BIDEN
BLOCKED EXPIRATION ON LANCE,
BLOCKED NEW DRILLING EFFORTS IN
ALASKA, KILLED THE KEYSTONE XL
PIPELINE, ENACTED A VARIETY OF
REGULATIONS ON THE OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY, AND HE NEEDS TO LIFT
THEM ALL NOW.
JOE BORELLI IS NOT WILLING OF
COURSE TO REVERSE COURSE ON ANY
OF THESE RESTRICTIONS NO MATTER
HOW HIGH THE PRICE OF A GALLON
OF GASOLINE GOES.
IT DOESN'T MATTER HOW MUCH YOU
PAY FOR GROCERIES AND EVERY
PRODUCT THAT YOU BUY IN ANY
STORE.
YOU THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL PAY
THE PRICE.
ONE OF THE BIG REASONS WE HAVE A
40 YEAR HIGH WITH INFLATION.
JOE BIDEN IS TOO COWARDLY, TOO
GUTLESS TO STAND UP TO THE
RADICAL CLIMATE ALARMIST CULT
THAT IS THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
BASE.
WHO WOULD RATHER JUST IMPORT THE
OIL FROM PUTIN.
MILLIONS OF BARRELS OF OIL FROM
OPEC, A MILLION FROM IRAN.
WE HAVEN'T DONE THAT SINCE 1991.
PUTIN BY THE WAY, WAS STILL
IMPORTING OIL AS HE WAS WAGING
ASSAULT ON HUMANITY IN UKRAINE.
HE'S KILLING EVEN WOMEN AND
CHILDREN, BUT ACCORDING TO
BIDEN, HIS BLOOD INVASION OF
UKRAINE HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
JOE'S WEAKNESS ON THE WORLD
STAGE OR THE HUMILIATING
WITHDRAWAL FROM AFGHANISTAN.
BY THE WAY, IT'S DAY 201 SINCE
HE ABANDONED THEIR FELLOW
AMERICANS THAT ARE TRAPPED
BEHIND ENEMY LINES IN
AFGHANISTAN.
ACCORDING TO JOE, PUTIN INVADED
UKRAINE BECAUSE OF JANUARY 6TH?
WRONG, JOE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> President Biden:
VLADIMIR PUTIN WAS COUNTING ON
BEING ABLE TO SPLIT UP THE
UNITED STATES.
LOOK.
HOW YOU FEEL IF YOU SAW THE
CROWDS STORM AND BREAK DOWN THE
DOORS OF THE BRITISH PARLIAMENT.
I THINK YOU WONDER, THAT'S WHAT
THE REST OF THE WORLD SAW.
IT'S NOT WHO WE ARE.
>> Sean: MAY BE THE SPEAKER OF
HOUSE AND THE MAYOR OF D.C. HAD
TAKEN DONALD TRUMP, AS REQUIRED
BY LAW, HE SIGNED OFF ON AS MANY
AS 20,000 NATIONAL GUARD TROOPS
ON THAT DAY, DID IT TWO DAYS
EARLIER.
MAYBE IF THEY LISTENED T